Rebecca Harris the nerd its key over
3,000 oh man
okay all right just gotta flex my hands
okay oh yeah yeah let's play some chess
okay this is one minute plenty of time
oh he likes to play this stuff I forgot
[Music]
[Music]
what does this mean he's doing things
let's play this move defend
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
let's go let's go it's good starts good
start
very nice starts okay nine more until
adoption rights
[Music]
I didn't mean I meant to play pawn to e5
but it's okay stay calm
[Music]
hmm I can defend 95 c6 is kind of weak
maybe not maybe this move interesting
configuration play this move transfer
through the D file
[Music]
[Music]
it's a fork
[Music]
this is a pin
I can hear the tilts from miles away
okay eight more let's go
[Music]
I'm playing a Kings Indian now
[Music]
hmm well it's bits thanks for the bits
you're a wizard Annie actual wizard when
upon
mmm rookie one coming mmm its playable
[Music]
what to do he's sevens hanging focused
in the center on the play rook c3
what does this look see for maybe how
what is that oh there's a trick though
there's a trick yes
oh he has the same trick what is this
witchcraft it was this position
it's an game-like
of 13 seconds no don't flag me
[Music]
No
I was a disgusting game we both had the
same trick
what is this endless ye6 now let's just
take
[Music]
what's going on here to defend e - oh no
this is bad unless it's not bad maybe
it's good
BAM
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
know what's going on
[Music]
ooh my winning
I'm winning
[Music]
no I worked oh I needed to pre move
every move there oh it's so painful so
painful
[Music]
well we're gonna have a special guest
very soon
special guests incoming i blundered no
yo i'm streaming guess who I'm playing
yes II guess yes do you know the name
Rebecca Harris blue weights i have comp
someone who you know pretty well welcome
to the stream Goldust Tori you play
tennis wait what with Bobby Wow
no way at the same courts we were at
Forest Park yeah
oh we were there too
[Music]
got me was like changes they like but
were you better than Fabi no no
hmm well he's been apparently taking
lessons I think no life isn't fair Danya
yeah it's so it's devastating I won the
first two games and now he's won like
three in a row
it's very shuttle like I was gonna end
the stream a while ago but I memorize
yeah so if you just want to like talk to
the chance hi everyone there was a wind
today yay that's exciting
especially for Fabi yeah it's been
trying so hard
hi John I did I'm pretty sure I was like
a handicap to all of them could we do
like double oh nice
all right thanks John you found my
interview ah dude that's like the first
thing everybody's insane to me like the
last couple everyone saw anyone who
watches chess on Lawrence a lot
John you haven't seen it it was put on
like the main coverage yesterday it was
really cool I like look up and I'm like
oh I'm on the big TV yeah yeah then we
got sushi with nice
you get with Ray for tennis I played a
long match with Ray as long as one of
the longest matches we've ever had and
now I'm just getting smashed but his
ratings much higher than mine so it's
not like the worst thing ever yeah tanya
is pretty good he's walking into opening
preparation this is nice
oh this is very nice this is so so nice
Keeney - maybe blond cloud wait where's
my win k3 and deep bishop takes maybe
fighting meets ah but that doesn't quite
work it's still a great position takes
and then be fancy this better work
bishops can't pretty sure this is gonna
hang everything's attacked kind of you
know everybody's been asking if I've
dyed my hair but I didn't I just got my
Ritz bleached so I look like I'm not
brunette
[Music]
my hair is kind of messed up
I go brush
he's playing on because he knows I'm
slow and weak just puts that's that's
good point the roof is not trapped okay
22 seconds should be plenty of time
[Music]
g5 BAM
25 just about building the structure
flying on the dark squares can't mess
with my dark squares empty - whoo let's
play riff d2 anyway other work to do too
with my third win it's not another that
score three to four oh that's actually
actually gonna felt worse I'm about to
break 2700 need one more win let's play
three Halloween gambits Halloween Gavin
it's the most enjoyable opening ever
[Music]
yeah I thought you'd be done streaming
aback ah well I was gonna finish but
then
Danya came in yeah people keep subbing
and cheering everyone if you have a
Twitter sasada if unused please use it
right now twitch pride twitch Brian
twitch prime please please or you can
just save it for Tory stream yeah oh
let's do this
okay I like my screen even though
mmm this is uncomfortable I said the
same the other day on my stream Shh
[Music]
being quiet I'm a strong independent
chess streamer named Tori this is really
uncomfortable
ah John thank you so much it gives you
it's up to Eric Rosen yes oh that song
it's my biggest fan I think
[Music]
oh my gosh am I getting needed it really
new master said I can't a root of event
I like that thank you uh I got me that I
was up a piece like a whole game it's
not easy
yeah it's one of the like sounds that
the game generates this kind of soothing
music I messed up my trap it's okay AJ's
position is okay
[Music]
so my goal is to break 2700 and then I'm
ending things but it's gonna still take
some work I think I wanna play rook 8/8
Queen defense oh there's gotta be a win
here rook takes h2 rook takes cheese
three no counter play don't even
calculate it solid advice I for oh
that's a check I didn't see that check
so there's counter play if I take it I
lose but I think I'm just getting
crushed
regardless Queenie ain't here here here
I think I'm losing
oh I went listening
so sad I don't know why I'm playing on
oh that's a no I mean that I would want
to be his manager so rough look at this
whoa yeah
I'm feel oMG oh yeah that's nice it was
me yeah not too many of the players are
like so active on social media during
the traces
oh he's he's a pro at like Twitter and
everything its Instagram
I'm the story thing it's that there's
stories on snapchat too but not better
than Tori thingies yeah exactly
[Music]
so who are you reading for between me
and Danya tough question Christian who
do you want to any such madness actually
[Music]
you should just do the sound effects no
need for computer
[Music]
let's play this move I am here now
pretty crazy trust me I know it's there
pretty crazy where else
[Music]
I want it I got it
and have it here
[Music]
three
[Music]
I'm trying to diamond cutter blbl I'm
trying to do the rosin trap he's not
gonna fall for it silver off this is
really rough
it's three to seven okay see if he falls
into crap again
who's the spline for mine who's this
each five to be aggressive pictures were
nice I can show them at the end once
this match is over with
I did that a little bit earlier but not
with all of them
[Music]
okay I like the the feeling of this game
I think yeah I mean you should root for
me just so the stream can finish it's
not what we want to hear Precog zero
I've not noticed it's better coffee nice
[Music]
are you serious this is not good I'm
trying but he found your tactic
I'm trying all no there's more weird
tactics
this is hanging okay he's gonna have
three minors for a rook at six BAM it's
too fat
[Music]
oh really trying my best lost so many in
a row
[Music]
okay we have a berry attack this is fun
opening it was very fun opening
[Music]
we're following creature coos new dean
off some year to h5 to do maybe queen in
d3 to prepare e4 Knight c1 ideas Wow
let's play f3 and I like the position
we're gonna trade Queens the rook in the
center maybe for now not sure if this is
leading to anything
trade ponds
some night is very sneaky c4 let's play
this move can be tricky
[Music]
see for there we go
[Music]
to get the Knight to e5 ouch
I take I think I can take that
no oh wait maybe maybe this is okay
[Music]
should be fine
c5 it's gonna be a pawn race I'm a long
time
[Music]
I'm really trying g5 c6
no it's mates oh I forgot he has meaning
ideas I'm sure you can keep yourself
entertained
maybe you have to do that to be
extremely six
[Music]
does this move to take I lost a pawn
please play 25 and be five interesting
[Music]
and go away with us takes while it is
this use just winning pawns all over the
place
okay I'm gonna win see to
after Claire bishops I lose another pawn
not what I want
of its playlist and Bishop a six
I gotta push pawns on the kingside hope
for something use some miracle Bishop to
Bishop f3
let's bring the King
the rook there
[Music]
hey Doug
what's up che doc oh no he's making
progress
stop it I can't you just keep late okay
I'm trying
[Music]
Rebecca Harris is not a woman
oh I hung a Brooke but he didn't see it
oh I hung a bishop now he saw it's over
you can't tell me tell me tell me please
tell me please tell me me all of
Sunstone it's the worst he's so good at
chess he's playing a dubious line it's
to punish him for it
and this move I think this works winds
up on intermezzo
okay this is my game this is my game two
men each five it stick
he's being tricky again stop being
tricky play f3 very safe and solid
oh he's gonna play B for some points
that's really annoying push what no but
then I lose all of her pawn
maybe Bishop d4 c3 was weak but maybe
this is okay Bishop b3 and then I'll
take very soon what to do 'if i maybe
g3f for
[Music]
okay G file action my Center solid
there's no play Bishop c5 maybe or that
we got six coming let's go let's go
rookie a rookie seven ideas pin and
Wayne kind of that's a pin I won upon
plan is this and then this and then back
each sixes of threats don't see it
please don't see it even if he sees it
he's in trouble he didn't see it let's
do this in this game
[Music]
get that one screw yes just move get it
just move love cars push up pretend him
Yasir push him baby
yeah yeah but I'm still not 2,700 I need
to win or draw one more yeah I know I'm
four points away I just need one draw
should do it making progress
okay let's play this line was this line
you see too interesting be fine baby
saved you six have a semi sloth what is
this before maybe take that take
it's play love do this
[Music]
okay weird position but I'm alive
running mate in one he saw it
play the smooth running on maybe
training this he's gonna take maybe
maybe not returning this
[Music]
we both have doubled pawns by five off
the Clare bishops efficienty sixes of
threats this work it might work
skewer Ahava his Queen the King f8
avoiding Queen d4 check aha here's this
move
no but then rotates what a trickster
draw maybe oh no I was expecting Ritchie
five not Queen g5 oh so sad so so sad
and I'm hoping for the same
okay he's playing something differently
[Music]
this is playable very positional
[Music]
back three coming no I hung a queen
while I hang a queen I'm losing focus
all I need is one win and then we end
the end the match Bishop g5 this is my
game no he's already played some dubious
opening
I mean he's usually tilted if he loses
like one or two games all I have to do
traitor
Oh does this work better work let's take
that first
hmm that doesn't work okay interesting
position I'm down upon but could be
worse
what to do let's trade stuff
I've the B file can't access b1 put the
work on before he wants to trap the
bishop was for h5 yes still want to play
rook before
I like to think I'm a social butterfly
sometimes
some days no I plundered on my stream I
never touch uh if it's necessary I will
sometimes there's still matrix kind of
[Music]
he's so fast why is he so fast
[Music]
I think I'm drawing I'm drawing but I
have eight seconds left okay easy draw
[Music]
yes I still I'm three points away I need
one more draw that was a miracle draw by
the way this shift color corner saves me
can we have a normal appearance
[Music]
very normal Puritans
[Music]
it was us 41 first for be three and then
they'll take the pawn
it's a good square for the Queen okay
three so ugly might be one so ugly all
of this is just so ugly that I'm alive
I'm winning upon maybe I want a pond
let's move back attack upon oh let's do
this
losing the exchange but it's not the end
of the world
[Music]
I have to what happens when if I choose
okay I'm coming back I'm coming back you
blundered don't think he'll be that
tilted but maybe he will
[Music]
oh this is so bad
I was coming back kind of
[Music]
it's still kind of alive
[Music]
I've won pawn
commenting the sky
[Music]
yeah people love the coast dreams I
can't stop me and down you can't stop no
baby baby the music is very interesting
[Music]
so sad it's not a bad match it could be
worse
getting rating overall if always almost
to draw yeah in the end game series
mm-hmm in my chest I come less and show
everyone the hey
and this is good opening again enjoying
playing these structures
hard to the Fen g3 just when the pawn
okay again this is this is my game to
win
[Music]
what to do rookie six maybe table on the
D file
[Music]
come up a pond but things are a bit
tricky see for maybe pawn is pinned c3
is interesting
wanna play c5 next upon his pins in the
meeting square but that his that move
was going on here
let's fight for the a file you can bring
the Q to d6
[Music]
very strange position I have a
breakthrough with c4 c4 is close to
working very close to working he's
scared
c4 works ok I'm winning now his endgame
it's all about making passed pawns see
this breakthrough oh he's tricky oh my
gosh am I losing this
Oh check tricky backwards okay I think
I'm winning this I think I'm winning
this
he's down on time to make sure these are
defended yeah this this is easy when I
believe or not
[Music]
oh my gosh this is gonna be a draw
[Music]
you know what that means yeah look at
this
Oh one game no 2726 ninety five plus
five is twenty seven hundred good games
yeah should we called Anya this is
perfect time to check out voice check I
don't know I doubt it
oh no I don't know how it works actually
if we can hear him she's okay that was
fun
what a game this was a weird this was a
really weird game also apologies I was
not looking at the chat but Tory took
over chat duties shout out to people
chests poems
Bruno rola staying around like the whole
stream Ahmad likes chest
okay I want to see this I mean I should
have been winning this whoa it's Tonya
hello hello Dania I don't know maybe
it's not maybe like there's issues cuz
OBS is using their mic I don't think
it's working
it says it says - I assume I've never
seen this thing before
no maybe it's not working Dania you're
amazing